I know you talked to Governor Haley last
week about the removal of the flag you
said you said that she gave you a call
yesterday to say that she'd reached a
place where she was ready to do this can
you tell us a little bit more about that
conversation and how she explained
herself in terms of her thinking well
thank you so much for having me governor
Haley grew up in bamberg South Carolina
as she grew up around that flag as she
said to me on one occasion she was too
dark in some quarters to be white and of
course in the two white to be black and
so she understood put this flag it was
doing to a lot of people and she decided
there was time for her to take a stand
and I applaud her for doing it and I am
hopeful that the South Carolina
legislature oz will codify the
sentiments that she expressed today so I
don't I didn't talk to her about how she
worked till way through all of this but
I watched her last Thursday noon at Mars
brown AME Church solar again later in
the afternoon after church and i'ma tell
you these murders had a tremendous
impact on her I saw it I felt it and
when I talked with her things she
whispered to me out of earshot of the
media lead me to the conclusion this is
a genuine growth pattern that she is
undertaken in regards to this flag what
did she whisper to you congressman what
you just told me how sorry she was about
this and she hoped that she could have
my support going forward on trying to
get the appropriate state response to
this that's why I've stayed here in
South Carolina rather than come back to
Washington today
and I'll be here tomorrow because i plan
to stand with her and the other john
course instead of the Corson a
Republican from here in Richland County
I was there with us today and though the
other guys may be going back to
Washington I think this is important
enough for me to stay around and see it
to the end and I'll be interacting with
all the families down in Charleston and
North Charleston the rest of the week
before some of the pinkness services on
Friday when congressman everybody
appreciates the service you're putting
in as governor Haley and you embraced as
she pulled away I'm pretty sure I saw
you wipe away a tear to I'm wondering
what was so emotional about that moment
for you it was no perspiration than a
tear I sweat very easily but this was a
very emotional thing for me I was
involved in that trying to find a
compromise that really resulted in the
flag coming off the Statehouse dome I
stayed home from Washington that day
whoever made the announcement and when
that compromise failed it failed because
when a few civil rights people objected
to the compromise the legislature
rejected the compromise and when they
put the flag where it is today that was
not the compromise that flag went to
where it is today out of defiance the
legislature defiantly put the flag in
front of the Statehouse the compromise
was to put the flag adjacent to the way
it half the monument in front of the way
it happened building that's what our
agreement was congressman Lee so it's
not yes sir no just let me ask you how
you just raised it the code the way you
were just saying raises the interesting
next question which is do you think that
the legislature is now going to be ready
just to now except that it's time to
take the flag down or do you think the
series could have difficulty actually
getting this done even after the
governor has made her appeal it's going
to be difficult it's not going to be
easy
unfortunately too many legislators are
more interested in whether or not
they're going to win the next election
then whether or not South Carolina will
win the future this ought to be a battle
for the future of our great state we
have too many young people that some 80
over eighty percent of my class
graduating from South constant in 1961
left South Carolina not because they
wanted to they left looking for
opportunities we need to be creating
opportunities here for everybody and
that flag is a blight on the state and I
would hope that we will move forward
together so that everybody will feel
welcome coming into the state I've had
african-american executives tell me that
they have turned down Congress job
offers in this state